we know that time in some sense is at
rock-bottom that which allows change to
take place right when we we say the time
is elapsed we notice that because things
now are different from how they were a
little while ago that's what we mean by
time elapsing but is time some
fundamental quality of reality or is it
something that our brains impose on our
perceptions to organize our experience
into some coherent framework that allows
us to survive I mean I can well imagine
that we have been under evolutionary
pressure over the millennia to organize
perception so that we can survive get
the next meal plan for the future all of
that would seemingly require that we
have a conception of time that we apply
to what we experience out there but that
doesn't mean time as we experience it is
real it doesn't mean that time as we
experiences how the world is actually
structured I mean there are many ideas
that people put forward the possibility
for instance that you know we all know
that matter is made of molecules and
atoms could it be the time is also made
of some kind of ingredient a molecule of
time an atom of time is that really what
time is at a fundamental level and what
if you had one of these ingredients in
time a constituent of time all by itself
would there be any hint of time as we
experience it or do you need many of
these ingredients in order to fill out
time as we know it I mean if I handed
you a molecule of h2o you wouldn't know
that it's wet that it can quench your
thirst right I mean the ingredient
doesn't necessarily bear a direct
relationship to the macroscopic emerging
qualities that many of those ingredients
when put together will yield like your
glass of water time could be the same
thing there might be ingredients of time
that bear no resemblance
the time as we experience it and yet
that might be the more fundamental way
that time is injected into the makeup of
reality
time travel is absolutely possible and
this is not some sort of weird sci-fi
thing that I'm talking about here Albert
Einstein taught us more than a hundred
years ago that time travel is possible
if you're focusing upon time travel to
the future and I'm not referring to the
silly saying that we all age right we're
all going into the future sure I'm
talking about if you wanted to leapfrog
into the future if you wanted to see
what the earth will be like a million
years from now Albert Einstein told us
how to do that in fact he told us two
ways of how to do it you can build a
spaceship go out into space near the
speed of light turn around and come back
imagine you go out for six months and
you turn around you come back for six
months you'll be one year older but he
taught us that your time is elapsing
much slower than time back on earth so
when you step out of your ship you're
one year older but Earth has gone
through many many years it can have gone
through ten thousand hundred or a
million years depending on how close to
the speed of light you traveled and he
also taught us if you go and hang out
near the edge of a black hole time again
will elapse more slowly for you at the
edge of the black hole then back on
Earth so you hang out there for a while
you come back and again you get out of
your ship and it will be any number of
years into the future whatever you want
all depending on how close you got to
the edge of the black hole and how long
you hung out there that is time travel
to the future now of course if people
really want to know about getting back
can you travel back to the past I don't
think so we don't know for sure no one
has given a definitive proof that you
can't travel to the past
in fact some very reputable scientists
have suggested ways that you might
travel to the past but every time we
look at the proposals in detail
it seems kind of clear that they're
right at the edge of the known laws of
physics and most of us feel that when
physics progresses to a point that we
understand things even better these
proposals just will be ruled out they
won't work but I guess I would say
there's a longshot possibility based on
what we know today that time travel to
the Past might be possible but most of
us wouldn't bet our life on it